we always have speech codes
the speech codes used to be that you
couldn't openly avow your allegiance
to the communist party in soviet russia
that might
have some professional consequences for
you that would incur some of program
now the speech codes mean that even if
you're a duly elected senator
you're not allowed to criticize the vice
president of the united states
if the vice president is a member of
certain protected and aggrieved
identity groups this we just learned
from kamala harris really we learned it
from
whoopi goldberg describing a an
interaction between kamala harris and
joe manchin so joe manchin
is the sort of moderate democrat from
west virginia kamala harris
radical democrat most radical member of
the senate back when she was
fully a senator now she's the vice
president but she'll also vote in the
senate
obviously they don't agree on a lot of
things so kamala harris did something
that was
pretty tough by political measures
they're trying to work out this new
stimulus deal
and kamala harris went down
to go on local television in west
virginia and arizona
two states where the democrats are a
little bit more conservative
to go circumvent those slightly more
conservative democratic senators
and try to convince the voters in those
states themselves
and put pressure on those senators to go
vote for the biden harris plan
without even talking to people like
cinema in arizona
or at joe manchin in west virginia
so joe manchin was very upset about this
and he expressed his displeasure on tv
i saw it i couldn't believe it no one
called me we're going to try to find a
bipartisan pathway for it i think we
need to
but we need to work together that's not
a way of working together what was done
fair enough it's not like he was out
there throwing bombs but he came out and
he said you know this
this was really unprofessional uncalled
for
you know pick up the phone let me know
what's going on don't go behind my back
to try to turn my voters
against me whoopi goldberg was very
offended not by what kamala harris did
but by what joe manchin did okay so let
me just point this out
joe she is the vice president she does
not work
for you she doesn't need your permission
to go do this
and when you talk like that it sounds a
little bigoted like you think
you have the right to tell her when she
can and cannot come someplace
so uh republicans are offering less than
a third of what
president biden requested less money for
emergency
employment benefits smaller checks for
individuals so
why would she need to come to you first
or would come to him first sonny when
she knows what she's supposed to be
talking about
this is such a cheap and lazy political
shot
i i when i'm considering all of the sort
of left-wing commentators out there
whoopi goldberg is one of my favorites i
actually don't i don't consider her the
worst of the worst
to me this just seems like she was
hastily putting her show notes together
and didn't want to take two seconds to
formulate
an interesting and serious thought about
it so she just plays the race card
but it's really really pathetic because
what she's saying
is kamala harris she doesn't work for
joe manchin
well first of all kamalaris is the is
the vice president right so she's not
the president
vice president not one of the most
important spots
in the federal government in this
administration she'll be
fairly important because she'll be
casting the tie-breaking vote but the
tie-breaking vote means she's got to
work with senators
right so her job is to work with the
senators
to get consensus and pass legislation
she especially needs to work with
members of her own party the democrats
one way to really undermine all of that
is to go behind their backs and apply a
lot of pressure to them in their own
states without even giving them a heads
up
forget calling them first without even
giving them a heads up
and joe manchin expressing his
displeasure do you think he's displeased
because kamala harris is black do you
think he's displeased because kamala
harris is a woman
no i think he's displeased because she
behaved in a very disrespectful and
unprofessional way
and they're supposed to work together
for the entire administration
does whoopi even believe that this is
about race or sex or something like that
i don't think so i think it's just so
easy that is the the reflex now
because uh speaking of standards our new
national standard
is this kind of bizarre racial and
sexual caste system
whereby you can just throw every sort of
complex issue or any kind of grievance
onto those matters it reminds me of when
david webb the
political commentator he had this woman
on
she was a black left-wing woman and they
were debating some issue
and it was a radio show so so she says
well david you only think that because
of your white privilege
and david starts laughing he said you
know if you knew me lady i
i don't think you'd make that claim she
goes no it's just because of your white
privilege
for those who don't know david david
webb is black he is not a white guy
he does not i i don't know i'm terribly
well but i've spent some time with the
guy
i've never seen any evidence of white
privilege you know dripping out of the
man
so she just said this to him because
it's just a reflex it's easy
sure throw it off that's what whoopi was
doing here and it's really
really dangerous for society to be to be
engaging in those sorts of things
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you